and the chief architect of elementary IP
sumit send you over there she is the CEO
of the company and she is also our
in-house machine learning experts so
which assuming we'll be presenting in
the second half the presentation so just
a brief introduction of who we are we
are Silicon Valley startup we started
back in April 2014 we build a SAS tool
for legal professionals or or patent
searchers to do pattern analysis and
patent management so we provide high
performance searching document
comparison side-by-side comparison
looking for similarities between
documents and we also do portfolio
analysis so the technology we use is
deep learning natural language
processing we heavily use open source
and we also have our own secret sauce
our proprietary algorithm in Python and
the reason why we're here today is that
we owe a lot to Python and open source
community we're here just to share our
experience and our learning so technical
overview I'll be presenting the overview
so what we're gonna do is to have a
overview high-level diagram a higher
high level description of the system and
different major software components and
share lessons that we have learned in
terms of architecture and then Sumi will
dive deeper into Python learning ok so
as I mentioned earlier we are we provide
a Search Search is not surprising really
whenever you go to any web application
you expect to have a search it's not
that hard if you're just doing a
out-of-the-box free text search because
you just put your documents in solar or
elasticsearch and there you go you have
a search what we're offering is a little
bit unique what we're offering is
similarity search there are two types of
similarity search that we're offering
one is the macro searching and the other
one is micro searching well what do we
mean by
go searching macro searching basically
given some phrase that you enter or in
our case even giving a a patent a lot of
times patent search you're given a
patent they want to look for
similarities what patterns that are
similar to the one that I'm looking at
so that's what we mean by macro
searching so given a pattern or given
some phrase in terms that you type in
and we return a list of patterns that
are similar to the ones that you're
looking at now the similarity not just
limited on synonyms a lot of times in
technical areas the technical terms
change over time even though they might
be talking about the same thing so so
that's macro searching and micro
searching is searching within the
document so this is providing a
side-by-side comparisons of to pattern
so when we say well those two patterns
are similar so oftentimes the searcher
wants to know well how are they similar
so micro searching providing a way for
the application to identify to the user
which area of the patterns are similar
and the ability to highlight the similar
areas within the pattern so similar
sentence is what we call so that allowed
the patent searcher to quick quickly go
through a large number of patents very
quickly so our application consists of
two parts
now what's behind the macro and micro
searching is work models we train work
models by processing Billings of terms
in hundreds of millions of patterns so
those two searches are based on the work
models that we created using machine
learning algorithm so the top part the
the pink processing is the back end
processing as you could imagine there's
a lot of document conching data
processing that's this the back end
that's all offline
batch processing we can't really do that
real-time because there's so much data
what's the real-time application the
bottom is the yellow apart
in addition so after we create a model
what we have is an online application
where people can log in and they do
their patent search and they can save
their pattern and they can
and then they we also have a
productivity tool to allow people to do
analysis to do annotations on the
pattern and come back later and save the
patterns and come back and look look at
the patterns further and then finally
the goal is to allow them to be able to
export what they what their findings are
so the key software components this is
mostly just the online application our
batch processing is primarily in Python
and this is the architecture or the
major software components for the online
application on the top of that is the
web server
the web server is Java Tomcat and so the
web server takes requests from the user
is a web application on the in the cloud
so the web server basically just
dispatching the user requires two
different software components Python
being one pythons the ability leveraging
high tones ability to return as the
related terms right given what the user
typing to be able to identify a list of
terms that could be potentially related
to what they enter and then do you
similarity search solar is allow it's
it's a search engine allow us to allow
user to be able to search on the
patterns that they have safe my sequel
is just a lot of is bookkeeping
relationship between annotation and user
and pattern so architecture this is the
beginning we started out with pretty
simple we wanted to keep things simple
so they're individual software
components type Python Java solar my
sequel they all run independently they
running on the host platform we have
developers on different platform some
are on Windows and Mac Linux pretty
diverse set of OS that worked well up to
a certain point until we know we have to
periodically update the libraries in
Python so the that creates a lot of
inefficiency because when you upgrade
Python especially the machine learning
packages a lot of times
it's water sensitive to the underlying
platform so what it has way is a
architecture challenge basically every
time we need to upgrade everyone has to
upgrade now we end up losing a lot of
hungry I was pretty small company we
can't afford to have people spend hours
upgrading their library so what we end
up doing is that we end up using docker
container ization basically we what we
do is that we create images on each one
of these software components we so each
one of them run independently and they
are they are isolated and so in in the
case that in the case that we use
stalker what we do is that now we all we
need to do is just build a docker image
once right so somebody just install the
latest library and publish the image
onto docker this is particularly true
with Python and the developers just need
to pull the dr. Python images into there
into the local system and then they run
the container off the image yeah so now
with the architecture is that in the
production side we went on google
calcloud operating system depending on
well if you are running on your local
machine you're not on cloud but you may
have different operating system Windows
Mac Linux and virtual machine if you're
on Linux you don't need to have a
virtual machine but if you're on Windows
your Mac you need to have a virtual
machine and then taco engine run on top
of that and on top of that the
containers that are specific to us to
our application does everybody know what
docker is yeah so I don't need to talk
about docker ok good ok
as a second knowledge could
architectural challenge we were running
pretty ok for a while until we hit some
performance problem we have what if you
can see on the Left diagram there we
have Python Java and the same can
you know the reason why we have them in
the same container is that because Java
actually explicitly called out make a
system call to Python whenever it needs
to call a Python function so there is a
problem with that especially when we
when a word model gets really large so
actually it we at a point that we hit a
roadblock basically the similarity
search cost us 26 seconds to run that's
totally not acceptable in real time so
what we end up doing is we break in
Python and Java we decouple them
basically so instead of having Java or
Python whenever we do that first of all
it needs to low Python into the system
into memory and second of all we have to
low the word model in the memory so now
we break Python separately and pythons
running as an independent server so
python will start up with the word model
already in memory and it's up and ready
to go and whenever java needs to have
some python invoke some Python function
we just need to do messaging so we send
a message over the socket and send it
over the Python and so we drop up with
our performance increase from you know
26 seconds to less than a second
actually so now we arrive at that point
at this point so now we have Python Java
solar my sequel they are all running in
their own separate container and we have
a little piece JavaScript for a
client-side user interaction and we use
the three for visualization
just for fun give you a couple examples
what we use D fee for d3 we use d3
at this point is to show the
relationship between terms so if you're
looking for the term wireless it using
our word model it returns a list of
related terms the size the circle
indicate how frequently the terms appear
in the documents and the edge between
the circle indicated how closely related
a term is to the root term wireless ok
so we have a couple
a visual reference representation when
it's the graph on the left and we also
have a tree graph for people who play
with the nice thing about d3 is it's
data-driven and also interactive you can
expand and close or you can drag it
around and it's kind of fun toy to for
people to play with and it's also a good
visualization okay with that
Sumi we'll talk about Python yeah the
total patterns are probably a hundred
million including global so for a
reasonable model we need about 2 billion
ish words which is about between fifty
thousand two hundred thousand patterns
so we look for patterns in the class
usually it makes sense to model one
technology class on its own otherwise
you have too much too many different
words with different contexts in the
same model so right now we're keeping
pattern classes different so patterns
are classified by their technology class
for those that may not have seen that
all right so let's look at the
algorithms a little bit detail so by the
way I'm a EE so if there are any basic
computer size questions that's what
happy alright
so it's a simple four stage data flow
acquisition processing err modeling and
similarity search we grab patterns from
the web you can grab them from the PTO
or other public sources then we do
natural language processing and save
proprietary metadata X in XML and HTML
then we use context based word models
and we use Jensen for that and finally
you end up with similarity search
similar terms sentences patterns and a
free text kind of a search the specific
packages most of you're familiar with
these beautiful soup which is awesome
and we use a lot of regular expressions
and ltk was what we started out with for
some of the data processing and I'll
talk about that further
Jennsen which is awesome really fast for
AI modeling and for similarity search we
further use num pian scikit-learn so
let's look at the performance challenges
a little bit deeper so at our first cut
of architecture here's what it looks
like
data acquisition is fast in the sense
that there's only so much you can do
about it it in the end it's the network
speed that dominates that data
processing is our slowest point right
now because we're doing a lot of stuff
we're doing a lot of NLP and then we're
trying to save it in in our own format
so that is the slowest point and we'll
deeper dive into that in the next few
slides
ai modeling Genzyme awesome it's
optimized insight on blazing fast we're
happy with that similarity searches a
little bit slow but we think we can
speed it up so let's deep dive into the
data processing in a little more detail
again it's a simple four stage process
use parts of speech tagging then we
chunk and save phrases which as all of
you know this is sort of rule-based you
know you're trying to get the right
nouns and not the junk objectives or the
verbs so we do this and we chunk the
parts of speech tags into groups noun or
verb phrases and in patterns because
they're written in this very strange
language of these the claims sometimes
the lawyers are deliberately trying to
confuse you and hide the actual
invention so you know it takes some work
to kind of sift out the legalese then we
combine similar phrases this is to clean
them up just for example if you want to
display a list of top most frequent
phrases to the user we want to combine
those that are similar lemmas or
conceptually overlapping and this is
actually a pretty intensive it started
up being a pretty intensive computer
intensive stage as well and then we mark
them up in that original text for
display as well as for use in XML and
other purposes so we started out with
NLT care for the first two stages very
slow so parts of speech tagging is
pretty slow and chunking is actually
okay combining was we had a very naive
implementation ee so forgot my CS and
then we marked them up in text which is
somewhat slow but not too bad
what we'll do now is look at sort of the
four stages and what we did to actually
bring the CS back in so partial speech
tagging um so the default and ot
categories is slow we tried this packet
it's Spacey um its new and it uses
psiphon just like Josh Jensen to
optimize speed we so we tagged just the
description section and we're showing
you two examples and the size of those
patterns in sentences and tokens um one
is small short is a small pattern there
longer pattern and we tried two
different approaches we tried tagging
them sentence by sentence or we sent in
the whole description the whole bulk
text into it
and we found very different behavior so
Spacey is actually 77 times faster than
an OT k for parts of speech tagging only
parts of speech tagging we didn't do
dependency parsing because we're not
there yet so just for that it's it's
faster for short sentences but if you
feed it like large sections of text it
loses its advantage so assume that
they're sentenced organization is slower
they're things are slow still in Spacey
but but if you can just spit in
sentences blazing fast and it's
higher-quality they're actually had
better better quality labels than n LT K
does n LT K for example couldn't figure
out the word comprise comprises a common
word and every pattern will have
comprised in the claims so didn't work
for us next phase is a phrase chunking
so we want to mark noun or verb phrases
because later on we want to use this
information now in phrases tend to be
more informative verbs are just too
generic sometimes to be even useful to
look at so we label them and there's
typically hundreds to thousands of these
phrases that we find per patent then the
question was um how do we store them and
then how do we figure out if we have
multiple instances of the same phrase
sometimes they are inconsistent so
because of errors in the underlying
tagging they don't always look like a
noun or a verb phrase so we had to then
use majority logic to reconcile the
different labels so we try two different
methods we tried cumulative smoothing
where we would save all of the phrase
labels
list and then go back and then try to
reconcile them with smoothing or we did
in place where we saved them as a
dictionary as items and the moment you
grab a new one
are you smoother right there so
obviously the dictionary smoothing is
faster it's a it's like a hash table and
it's 40% faster than using a list so
that's that's useful learning we can
immediately implement that so the next
stage I'm actually gonna switch the
stages a little bit I'm gonna talk about
marking up phrases first so after we
clean them up we want to mark them up in
XML or HTML and we tried regular
expression versus string and we found
that string is 44% faster and these are
all results for 20 patterns so we expect
they'll scale hugely for hundreds of
thousands of pounds but we're happy to
see these you know close to 50%
improvements so this is the actually the
third stage where we combine similar
phrases and here again we have a choice
we had to get creative with using the
string strength of Python first we did
try the list so we want to combine
phrases that have commonality like
packets which packet-switching fast
packet switching networks conceptually
they're all about the same thing so when
when we show them to the user we should
want to show them as a cluster so we
tried two approaches for the list we
grabbed the phrases first we took all
the phrases and their count and then we
did pairwise regular expression
comparisons and for the string approach
which we created this less a string with
the phrase index in the phrase and then
we used a regular expression for each
phrase to look for locations so it turns
out that the string representation is
eight times faster than the list
representation so from the very
beginning to the very end and we have
these incremental improvements where we
compute regex on-the-fly then we store
the regular expression I had a time and
then we saw only indices and not the
actual phrases and in the end when we
went to string boom who was the fastest
we didn't have to do any of those
incremental improvements so string is a
very interesting alternative to actually
using lists if you can cause the problem
like that and so for this section the
next steps are to try to reduce this
approximately eight seconds processing
time it's still non real-time so we want
to see how far we can push it in Python
before we have to resort to scythe on or
numpy or or another option and on
similarity search some of what we did
for data processing will help with the
similarity search as well and then we're
going to Dulce ler
and see how we can incorporate the AI
word models directly and solar without
losing performance so next I'll show you
some fun examples of what we found into
some pattern classes so the word phone
in a telecommunications class 705 on the
left side what you see is the first
layer of nearest neighbors so this is
using the model that we created the
jensen model so the closest were
telephone pager or cellular telephones
make sense you expect that on the right
side we expanded the further the nearest
neighbors so a nice thing here is I mean
do this so you see two different
clusters emerge on the rightmost we have
landline phones so some of you may not
have used a landline phone if you're
young enough so we have landline phones
a fixed line wireline pots a very
ancient technology on the left side of
that we have cellular wireless mobile
walkie talkie cordless handset so it's
nice that they're semantically related
clusters as well so if you have enough
data this actually starts to make sense
and starts to be useful and informative
yes
yeah so we started out just by doing a
very raw model first because we wanted
to capture nuances like you know there
are errors and patterns so entities like
company names right if there's an error
it'll be misspelled it'll be a it'll be
a it'll be a upper capped lower caps so
you wanted to see what it would do with
the raw data first and we're obviously
we're gonna go to a stemming next we're
gonna go to multi-word phrases and all
that so we started out with just the
simplest possible single token model to
see what that would give us and we
actually learned a lot of things even as
part of that before we lunge the data
too much so these are all the examples
for the first generation examples so
fracking we looked in the u.s. class 166
which has to do with oil wells so we
enter fracking on the left side you see
the first layer of neighbors so phrasing
I thought that was a typo
where's that where did the K go but then
I looked up some of the patterns that
had phrasing and some of the older
patterns actually use the word phrasing
instead of fracking so I wouldn't have
known that right as a non-expert and
this model just boom racing so searchers
like this because surgeons have to spend
so much time patent professional patent
searchers they have to first explore a
little look at a few patents understand
the terms search again to find their
terms and that takes days so with this
one button and you're at least know you
know what are the close terms and then
fracturing which is more frequently used
so more patents have fracturing and
facing is actually a smaller above
smaller bubble and then hydro fracturing
and then words like job water sand are
modifiers fracking job water sand
fracking so the other reason we did the
single tokens was we wanted to see how
the modifiers would behave relative to
synonyms relative to other linguistic
relations like Homer name's holo names
blah blah blah we wanted to see what
this would do with that before we
artificially constrained the data and
then there's something funny called huff
and puff on the leftmost so what has
happened buff let's actually do this so
that
have to do with flooding some kind of
water gas flooding technique in oil
wells part of fracking all right now
that we fracked the hell out of the
environment let's go to looking at
entities so we can do the same thing for
pretty much any text right so we can
arrange the text so that we look at what
companies are filing patents with
similar titles so these are
relationships based on titles on the
left side we have Google on the right
side we have Facebook and for this
pattern class which is about
monetization of software so it's a
patent it's a class about software we
see that Google has many more patents
than Facebook in that class at least
according to the model it may be
inaccurate and the interesting thing is
their neighbors they are each other's
nearest neighbor so Facebook and Google
are that close they're each other's
nearest neighbor in this pattern class
and then their nearest neighbors aren't
very similar so both of them happen to
have eBay Amazon Zynga a nine oh so they
have very similar neighbors so that's
interesting there's a deeper but that
means there's if you didn't know about
Google or Facebook or even if you did
you can actually find out very
interesting things from such
relationships you can find about trolls
so I don't have an example in this
particular case yet but another class I
looked at where I know the space better
like in wireless so some of the
companies that are actively filing
patents in order to then later on
litigate and and pursue you know larger
companies you can actually tell from
this because there's their titles tend
to be similar because the filing about
the same topic or if there are
transactions when companies are buying
and selling patterns that tends to get
reflected here so for example we see
that face myspace is still around and
presumably some of those bands might
have gotten sold to Facebook so myspace
is still around so there's there's all
these interesting relationships that we
can see and some of them actually make
sense in the business world as well
although it's just a statistical model
from where Dobek so comparison to legacy
search
we're just showing one example here
we're doing larger-scale customer
studies so what this shows is closer to
traditional information retrieval so
what we did was we took a bunch of
patterns that are similar to the first
one seven five of seven four five oh
four eight nine and we ranked them by
their score in the similarity search and
then we did a legacy search which is
purely keywords based and that's
typically what most people do in the
legal industry right now especially in
patterns so there is a keyword boolean
search and we see that similarity search
because it because it is a software
search it found two very similar
patterns and they're actually close
enough to make a very good legal case
for any of these involved companies but
you know I won't tell them that they'll
probably not want to know and then the
legacy search actually the red just
misses misses all of them because it is
so narrow
it is very keyword based but the
similarity search because it's using
those other models the nearest neighbors
that we found automatically is able to
find do much better job and this is just
one example so our key takeaways from
these are experiments with with with
this in Python so the AI NLP packages
they range from the educational ltk to
the industrial Jensen and Spacey um for
general algorithms a real-time speed is
a challenge it takes a lot of work to
really tune them and it would be nice if
there were a concept library of typical
algorithms and they're optimized designs
and an easy way to search I don't know
if I mean Stack Overflow so far is how
we how we go about it right is you just
keep looking until you find something in
Stack Overflow to optimize some one
stage and then obviously Python Java
soulard they're each doing specific
things that that we want to leverage for
example for our to speed up the
similarity search we want to somehow
incorporate it into solar and these
interfaces have to be designed carefully
and then functions have to be
partitioned carefully about you know are
you really leveraging what that
particular block provides and
containerization really helped us speed
up deployment and
implementation generally and that is all
we're gonna talk about if there's any
questions so the question is a Jen sim
does topic modeling's how does our POS
tagging relate to Jensen
so we're not using their topic modeling
we're using their award model word
vector models so our parts of speech
tagging and the phrase chunking goes
into Jensen on top of which the models
are built and the results assured you
actually only they do not include the
advanced part of speech time that I
talked about yet those were single token
examples yes
and so the question is is prior art
search the main application this can be
used for all legal search general search
right um prior is are sort of the lowest
hanging fruit because it is patent
against patent so since we're modeling
on patents it's very easy to compare to
patents but we can and we're planning to
extend it to non patent literature where
you can do infringement you can do
freedom to operate and all other kinds
of searches but that does also require
being able to you know crawl the web and
get all the data automatically and other
things but but we can easily compare a
non patent document to a patent we just
need the model so what Tammy showed you
the beginning we do this offline model
building and online comparison so once
you have the model which is if it's
broad enough you can compare any
document and you know hopefully the
words that are in the document will also
be in your model most of the time yes
yes so the question is are we using word
tobik are we using clustering on top so
the answer is yes to both and then in
addition to clustering I mean you have
to do some fairly advanced so patents
are structured they're very structured
documents so we do some fairly not quite
rule-based but you have to think
rule-based
to come up with useful clustering for
patterns based on different pattern
fields
and so the question is are we using any
particular clustering algorithm so we
tried actually we did try all of them up
we tried k k-means we tried affinity
propagation so we like affinity
propagation but but it tends to be
imbalanced sometimes so we we right now
we're okay with k-means and you have to
play with the number of clusters though
so if you have too many or too little
things start to look weird so we had
really had to slap it into shape and you
know try this try that until it looked
reasonable but it's a little fragile in
that sense right because it's so of hand
picked so they yeah that's a good topic
um so one interesting thing in
clustering is took topological modeling
and topological clustering out of
there's a company to remember their name
out of Stanford so that's actually very
interesting because k-means and affinity
propagation are there more vector space
based and they they kind of put
everything into one bucket affinity
propagation the nice thing with that is
it looks for non planar non linear
relationships and it's more interesting
and then tuple topological modeling is
even more nonlinear so we want to move
to topological clustering I should say
to political clustering if when we can
and we're kind of using that already a
little bit so yeah so if so you in order
to differentiate right from from anybody
who grabs just world Oh back off the
shelf there's a heck of a lot of work
that that goes into actually making this
work yes
so the question is how can we
incorporate user feedback real-time or
otherwise back into the search and
that's a great question because it
relates to the clustering question um
just draw world the back models are very
noisy everything is similar to
everything with a non-zero number right
everything is similar to everything so
you get a lot of noise so that takes
some work to fine tune those algorithms
and then certainly we think that the
sort of goal test will be if I had
perfect user feedback into my synonyms
or other words if I already knew what
the right words to use the similar words
were so we are we are building that into
our model where we you know there's an
option for the user to select from that
that circle you saw that these are the
words to use for this project and people
like that idea they want a control over
what the synonyms are so yes definitely
of interest yes the question is how do
we validate the models a benchmark them
against what
Oh test versus training um that's a good
question so I mean we could do some
abstract experiments to you know look at
some train data versus this and this as
you know is completely unsupervised
right so it's just in the wild you look
for some close context-based close terms
um but we think it's more fruitful and a
better use hard our time very limited
time to UM just go directly to the user
and have them do trials right and then
if they like it's in the end its
objective right that's the problem with
search you can never you can't even
measure perfect recall or perfect
precision right it's subjective so so
we're going straight to users and you
know just getting them to say okay is
this is this getting you something you
can't do today right is it buying you
something that's worth worth your time
because just the fact that you can have
the automatic extraction of similar
words is I mean it's it's amazing that
you know in the 21st century people are
still having to stick in one word see
what comes back read the patent stick in
a different word right so that's a lot
of time so even simply having the
vocabulary in front of them we think
will be very valuable and actually
people pay for these vocabularies the
patent offices they have these the
examiners they have these proprietary
you know glossaries that they all use
and apparently people pay money for that
so where do I can just pop out pop on
you know a lot more
yeah
so so that's a it's it's still a it's a
that's a good topic for I would say at
this point research we're trying a few
things so the interesting thing we've
seen is that statistics help so if you
cluster sentences it actually it's
really good so the more the longer your
sentences and then clustering them is
actually fairly accurate so it's
actually probably better to do things
that are larger you know with the longer
piece of data but that's definitely a
topic research we I we tried to use doc
to vac a little bit it was a little
clumsy to use and it at least would we
haven't really you know done much with
it um it seemed slower we just need to
maybe look at that but but we wanted to
start with the simplest part of the
reason is we want to look for here's
another important thing we try to
extract is what is the core invention of
a patent so some of our topology
topological clustering goes into looking
for what is the invention in a patent
normally you have to just read it many
many times to understand what the heck
is the pattern about right but but using
these we can also sort of look for the
you know the things that stand out so
when people are patenting something it's
it's it's a new collection of concepts
it's an unusual collection of concepts
so that is something we're also able to
extract with this and we wanted to keep
it at the world level because it's in
the end the unit the granularity unit we
have is words the moment we start to
budge it munch it up it loses the you
know the kind of an information but
that's just our approach
the chunks oh the number of phrases per
patent yeah how big is the class um
class is very yeah so yeah yeah so um so
that's a it's a good that's it up to the
design choice how you want to do it um
we've seen a one company that you know
builds our model across the entire
pattern database but then you're you're
have differentiation between classes
then you're back to something that looks
like this but it is much denser because
it has so many more contexts it's it's
combining and it makes it harder so
that's a design choice yeah yeah you got
to mind - you could combine similar ones
but you still so this is what Google's
new pattern website does is that they
use um they model the entire patent and
they use you know some kind of a vector
model but it's for the entire it's like
a document model um so they use that um
so it does help you at the macro level
but you can't get this kind of
granularity you know with with that
model so you still have to use maybe two
models hybrid yeah we wanted to get the
intuition right with first order to make
sense of it that does it actually give a
semantically useful information or not
at a granular level at a controlled
level before we try to grab too much
data into it yeah
you have to ask the difficult question
so question is how do you sell your
product given that there are infinite
numbers of patent search tools out there
so yeah so that's that's another
strategy in in differentiation and sales
so it's the easy or the easy a good
thing for us is this is the latest
technology and and legal is a very slow
space right evolution of technology and
legal is a real how many years behind
usually the rest of the industry so
we're obviously you know building the
right relationships and and in the end
the customer it's up to the customer so
the few lawyers like we were talking to
a relatively senior attorney at a large
social networking company and what they
told us was um they would use this every
day
just the fact they can get a bird's-eye
view of the world and then they can do a
quick comparison of two patterns so
simple productivity things we can do
with the similar sentence search is also
very valuable because when companies are
filing pens they wanna do a first and
internal check right because because
multiple inventors are finding the same
thing again and again and we know that
we were our patent committees and big
companies people are just trying to get
their score up but it's not it's an
incremental invention so lawyers gonna
check that quickly without having to pay
somebody external to do a search right
so this is a this is actually more
valuable to the to the IP lawyers and
attorneys who just want to do a quick
conceptual check right and decide that
so we think corporate lawyers will be a
good target for us and then then we also
want to move to the solo attorneys who
can't afford these expensive tools right
so there are totally dominant players in
patent tools and they charge upwards of
twenty five thousand fifty thousand
dollars a year and solo attorneys and
there's more solo attorneys that can't
afford that
so that's gonna be another market but it
is a small market and we think that if
we take the overall legal market not
just patents but other legal literature
then it becomes interesting
you